we are just moments away from the
Dancing with the Stars finale and all
bets are on bindi to me this this whole
experience is the sixth time experience
has changed my life
bhindi broke down at the end of her
finale dance her partner Derek secretly
arranged for a photo of her with her
late father to appear on the stage
you've broke the news that she didn't
know that that photo was going to come
up he decided to keep it from her it was
this lovely photo of her and her father
and the producers knew she just said I
had no idea you were going to do that
I'm sure the viewers at home were crying
but tell us what it felt like in the
room to watch that live It was as if
everyone has to take a moment
it was poignant and it was powerful and
it felt larger than the show and you can
expect more tears tonight now a portion
of tonight's two-hour season finale will
be broadcast live from here at the Grove
shopping center we've got new video of
the final three in rehearsal late this
morning that's Alek skarlatos with his
partner Nick Carter singing and Derek
will do him but here is the big question
can anyone beat Ben D here are four
reasons why she is definitely the
front-runner number one story
bhindi story is so compelling because we
all felt connected to her dad Steve
Irwin and now we've grown to love her as
a person we knew her family and now we
know bindi reason number 2 bindis
partner Derek now look as a former
competitor I can tell you this is a
major factor Derek is a fierce
competitor and by the way he's won the
Mirrorball record five times not to
mention he's won two Emmys first
choreography the third reason all bets
are on bindi is that she is truly an
incredibly gifted dancer then they had
no training before this and she's gotten
multiple perfect scores on the show and
finally reason number four
bindis attitude she is so hard-working
after the show on the press line she is
the first to arrive to do interviews and
the last to leave she's also so positive
so upbeat I've interviewed her multiple
times and I have never heard bindi say a
bad word about anyone and we are going
to see what happens tonight now no
matter what it will be
an amazing show now remember all the
stars will be back to dance one last
time I will be there right in the
ballroom and have it all for you
tomorrow